DANIELLE: Is that it?
MIKE: That's it?
DANIELLE: That's
gotta be it, right?
MIKE: Wow.
DANIELLE: Yeah.
MIKE: God,
this place is killer!
DANIELLE: Oh, yeah.
MIKE: You don't even see it!
MIKE: Hey, Dani.
DANIELLE: Hi, Sue.
SUE: Hi.
DANIELLE: I'm Danielle.
We spoke on the phone.
I told you I'd be
coming in today.
MIKE: Hey, I'm Mike.
DANIELLE: This is Mike.
SUE: Oh, yeah, hey.
Let me grab my husband.
DANIELLE: Awesome, yeah.
MIKE: Alright.
SUE: Jack.
JACK: Yeah.
DANIELLE: There's that.
JACK: Nice to meet ya.
DANIELLE: This is what we
talked about on the phone.
Hey.
MIKE: Hey, nice to meet ya.
DANIELLE: Nice
to finally see you.
MIKE: Yeah,
that's a list of the stuff...
MIKE: What year is the building
underneath the ivy?
JACK: 1930.
My dad bought it
in the early '70s.
JACK: My father bought
the Homestead Building, totally
for storing car parts,
and for storing cars.
MIKE: Oh my gosh,
look at this side of it!
So how do you get in it?
JACK: We can get into
the building through this hole.
DANIELLE: We're going
in through the hole?
Okay.
SUE: This is where I stop.
I'm going shopping.
Have fun today! [laughter]
SUE: You can do your own
shopping... bye-bye!
MIKE: Alright,
it's good to meet ya.
SUE: Nice seeing you.
DANIELLE: We'll
see you in a bit.
SUE: Bye-bye.
DANIELLE: Thank you so much.
MIKE: Alright, Dani,
you want to go first?
DANIELLE: I think
I'll let you go first.
For sure.
♪
MIKE: Alright...
JACK: You need a hand?
MIKE: I got...
DANIELLE: Yeah, you got it.
MIKE: Woo!
♪
DANIELLE: Alright.
Flashlight's on.
MIKE: Man, this is cool.
Wow.
DANIELLE: [gasps]
This is incredible.
DANIELLE: When was the last time
this was actually opened up?
JACK: Probably in the '70s.
DANIELLE: Really?
MIKE: No kidding.
JACK: It's been a long time
since I've been
in that building,
but it's pretty much exactly
the way I remember it.
MIKE: Wow.
JACK: Okay,
the first two steps are...
questionable.
DANIELLE: Alright.
JACK: Bring your light,
walk on the left.
DANIELLE: Like many of
my life choices, I suppose.
Ooh, yeah, they are
questionable, at best.
JACK: I think that's
just from moisture, though.
DANIELLE: Ugh!
Whoa...
MIKE: You got it?
JACK: Yeah.
MIKE: Pretty sketchy.
DANIELLE: Ooh!
Wow...
MIKE: Danielle and I walk
into a room that's packed
full of stuff.
I'm talking layers of it.
MIKE: Oh, I saw some
sign hangers over here.
These are great.
They're original.
Guys that collect signs,
you know, or have signs
that want to display them
the way they were,
these are perfect for it.
JACK: What year do
you think they are?
MIKE: You know, early teens,
into the '40s, you know?
JACK: Yeah.
Probably.
MIKE: How about these,
would you sell these?
JACK: Yeah, these can go away.
MIKE: I'd do, um...
45 bucks apiece.
JACK: So 90 bucks
for both of them.
MIKE: Yeah.
JACK: Sold.
MIKE: Okay, cool.
Alright, love it, man.
Appreciate it.
DANIELLE: Jack had not
been in that building
in over 30 years.
But what I love
is that he shared
that process with us.
SUE: Wow...
DANIELLE: Got some
fun stuff happening.
MIKE: Hey, sold a few things.
SUE: Looks like
you had a busy day.
MIKE: I did.
MIKE: Hey... thank you
guys for having us.
SUE: Fun day, fun day.
Good to meet you.
MIKE: I appreciate you,
seriously.
DANIELLE: Yeah.
I'd give you a hug but, aw...
[inaudible]
MIKE: Alright.
DANIELLE: Thank you
for everything.
MIKE: Dani, you driving?
DANIELLE: Thank you so much.
[honks horn]
SUE: Bye, safe trip!
DANIELLE: Bye, Jack!
Bye, Sue!
JACK: See ya.
SUE: Come back soon!